Much of the sports
world will turn its attention
to the semifinals of the World Cup.
But some are choosing
not to watch the games
out of a moral objection
from a migrant workers
who helped bring the tournament
Or refusing to tune in
because it reminds them
of the horrible conditions they
CNN's Larry Mid-Ohio has their s
Boniface Baraza is back in Kenya
but says he's still suffering fr
after three years
as a construction worker in Qata
before the World Cup.
I saw this
professor calling on a Kenyan
lizard, black monkey
Then when is it the Kenyan
counterpart, Bucky, asking
why you call him the black monke
And he slapped the supervisor,
slapped with a cap
and then
the 38 year
old is a lifelong football fan,
but says he hasn't watched any m
The pain is still too fresh.
Another one died
on that knee, Neal.
I shall have a condition.
When my colleague died,
another one was beaten and was
and he went missing.
You saw somebody die in front of
Somebody collapsed and died
and I think that was
because of the high river condit
because of the heat,
the limited drinking water track
Last month, the Qatar world
Cup chief acknowledged
that 400 to 500
migrant workers have died
on projects connected to the tou
as the World Cup got underway.
Some black migrant workers
have taken on highly visible rol
in a country where they're often
invisible part of the workforce,
but not the society.
Kenyan traffic officer Dennis Ka
handing out
red and yellow
cards, entertains fans
and has attracted global media a
And 23 year old Kenyan Abu Bakar
Abbas has become a viral megasta
as Metro Guy.
Organizers
even brought him up to address
fans before the England USA game
The same, but advocates
of migrant workers
dismissed these as isolated case
and empty
PR that had a dark,
exploitative work environment.
As we speak,
we still have people not getting
People are still living in
cramped conditions.
We have people
still facing physical,
verbal, sexual assault, discrimi
long working hours,
working conditions,
horrible working conditions.
Malcolm Bidali
was a security guard in Qatar,
but says he was detained
for advocating
for migrant workers rights.
I am very worried and scared
and concerned
when the World Cup ends
because like all the media spotl
and everything else
will know,
shift and move away
to the next big thing.
Qatar says it dismantled the pre
restrictive migrant labor system
which has been criticized across
for exploiting foreign workers
from Africa and South Asia
and taking away their passports.
But critics say
the reality has not changed.
Jeffrey Owino, was a safety insp
at Lusail Stadium
who believes he, too,
was deported from Qatar
for speaking up for migrant work
The African migrant workers
complain of exploitation
despite all these changes,
Qatar says it's put in place on
The laws are very good,
but implementation and goodwill
from the government of Qatar
is the problem.
That's
why workers will continue compla
until a framework,
a robust justice system is put i
whereby violators of these laws
migrant workers are punished.
Jeffrey says he receives
complaints and distress
calls from migrant workers
all over the Gulf,
desperate to return home
Organizers of the World
Cup told CNN that it would need
names and dates and ID numbers
before it can respond
to those allegations.
And a report about discriminatio
racism, verbal
and physical abuse,
even deaths of migrants
during the building of the World
But they've previously told CNN
that any allegations
of migrant workers
being targeted or detained
for speaking up are untrue.
And so here's the thing.
FIFA inspectors did
go to these sites
during the building of the World
Cup stadiums, and whenever they
Migrant workers tell us
they were told to behave otherwi
They don't know
what could have happened to them
They could have been sent home
or could have lost their jobs.
So they became good employees
and said, yes, we're being treat
And so one of the migrant worker
I spoke to said he's
too traumatized
to even watch the World Cup.
He doesn't even want to see Qata
Another one said
he compared the conditions
of living in Qatar
as a black
migrant worker to modern day sla
And that is the backdrop
for this expensive World Cup.
$20 billion builds on this World
and the labor of black and brown
from Nepal and India and Banglad
many of them also from here in
Kenya and Uganda. Max.